[Music]
all right everyone
another episode of history hyenas we're
gonna we're gonna do an episode about an
italian kid
harry houdini giannis pappas is on the
uh in the zoom at any moment uh his wife
could give birth and we're gonna just
fought the cam
pimp's gonna follow along all the way to
the birthing canal
yeah i am here via zoom uh waiting for
my wife's
little child to pop out so
we're zoomie zoom zoom this is about a
really cute italian kid
maybe he was parisian i don't know he
changed his name to houdini he added an
i it's just like what maurice did with
the a she was maurice and then she
became maurice ah
he had a book by a guy named houdini and
he had he added an eye and became that
guy
he's trans your dad because when your
dad pictures of your dad
your dad was a [ __ ] jack diesel kid
just like houdini
and i'm and my dad was just a fat fat
fat [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
so i mean at least you had a diesel dad
my dad was a diesel dad
he my dad was a guy he liked to do a lot
of different things
so he was yeah he was like he was like
houdini
and he's like you he he liked to keep a
lot of balls moving at the same time
that was a lifeguard he was a
firefighter he worked at the diner
he played football he went he wanted to
experience
life a lot of things and houdini himself
he
kept it moving babe the guy started in
magic he went on to be comedian
he did seances he [ __ ] catholic women
he traveled to england
he tried to contact his mom and then he
went on
towards the end of his life he went on a
crusade to say that all mediums were
full of [ __ ]
and that's really the most interesting
part about houdini
because let's just be honest the kid did
a bunch of [ __ ] magic tricks
that made black people go crazy and then
he wanted to talk about the truth
and give you a long day and so the last
part of his life is the one that i like
because it was a long day
yeah it's a long [ __ ] day and what
was his dying words again
his dying words were i'm a fake i'm
mostly a fake it's all fake
so it's what it is yeah it's worthless
dope
it's my my dying words are going to be i
just want some fakes
i think your dying words we all know
what they're going to be and they're
going to be like
i've lo i like men i like men
i love that yeah i love men i just like
men
his real name is einrich and his first
trick that he he performed at nine years
old
uh as a trapeze act and he called
himself einrich
the prince of the air so that's a little
bit too long
and not as good as harry houdini and
that's what it is seventeen-year-old
einrich einrich vicente wifer whatever
his original name was
read an autobiography by french magician
robert houdini
considered to be the father of modern
magic and then a friend told him if you
add an
i to that name in french it means like
them so that's where i got
houdini from it's because he read the
book by the french magician
i got it okay yes the thing that's
fascinating about houdini
and you know everyone knows houdini the
most famous [ __ ]
considered the father of magic the thing
that made houdini houdini though wasn't
really the tricks
because let's be honest a lot of
magicians can do that tricks sleight of
hand i mean nate bargatsi's pops is a
magician there's a lot of magicians
you know um but what made him different
was he was really the father
of doing real stunts
that kind of pushed the limit of what
reality is or what was possible
and he did this by conditioning himself
by having a bathtub in his house that
was oversized and he would hold his
breath
and go longer and longer and longer and
he would put needles through himself and
do all this stuff and
and get himself out of handcuffs by
practicing to use his feet
as fingers and and be flexible and
things like that
that were real and
pushed what was possible he was
definitely a
skookus a week he was a little guy
he should be squeaking a week next week
he was a [ __ ] squeak
but you know what the funny thing is
back in the day people a lot of people
were squeaks
we only started getting big till we
started eating mcdonald's
it's what it's true it's true and most
major magicians aren't really that tall
i guess you can't be really that tall
to pull these [ __ ] tricks off no yeah
no because if there's a chance during
your show you might have to get on a
horse you got to be a little kid
because those are those are the
squeakiest of squeaks for aerodynamic
reasons
the jockeys are small because they want
to do little less wind resistance
to slow them down so you know they're
they're squeaky but they're
definitely aerodynamically designed so
the way houdini died was
part of what he would do is he would go
around and he would challenge people to
punch him in the stomach
so yeah yeah like what you know when you
get around bobby kelly you just get
tempted because it's just mushy
it's just mushy yeah you hit him and his
shorts fall down yeah
so he would challenge kids to punch him
in the stung because he had built up his
ab muscles so much
and he had trained himself to take so
many blows it's kind of like when
kickboxers kick
trees to build up that [ __ ] strength
so
one kid just was a little too strong i
think he might have asked like a lenny
from a mice and [ __ ] kid to punch
him in the stomach
and yeah he just [ __ ] hooked them off
he just pulled
one off because it was john a light who
came to see him in a different way
and he just hooked one off on houdini he
hooked one off
and houdini died from being punched in
the stomach
oh yeah because it ruptured his appendix
eruption his appendix and he [ __ ]
died so he died in a hilarious way
and of course like we mentioned earlier
a lot of people thought he was murdered
by a lot of the mediums who got together
and said we got to do something about
this guy who's ruining our [ __ ]
hustle
and they came and saw him in a different
way and framed it
there's always conspiracy because
there's always going to be conspiracies
you know it's just they're
always going to be conspiracies
[Music]
oh